deutschland zieht die notbremse ab
morgen sollen grenzkontrollen zu
tschechien und tirol die gefährlichen
virus mutanten draußen halten zeugin der
anklage im pitch bend für prozess gegen
ex-präsident rammt wollen die demokraten
mindestens eine abgeordnete befragen
sensation in silber völlig überraschend
rast kira weigel bei der ski wm auf
platz zwei ein deutscher erfolg wie
zuletzt vor einem vierteljahrhundert
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am samstag mit viel
wintersport und norbert könig und die
korona zahlen sinken doch aus furcht vor
den ansteckenden mutanten macht
deutschland seine grenzen im südosten
für viele dicht damit die britische und
die südafrikanische variante des corona
virus die derzeit in den nachbarländern
grassieren nicht ins land kommen
kontrolliert wird abkommen der nacht in
sachsen und bayern an den grenzen nach
tschechien und tirol einreisen dürfen
dann noch deutsche ausländer mit
wohnsitz in deutschland
landwirtschaftliche saisonkräfte
gesundheitspersonal und lkw-fahrer für
alle gilt sie brauchen einen aktuellen
negativen krone test andere menschen die
normalerweise pendelt dürfen wohl nicht
einreisen nicht nur das stößt auf
massive kritik
sibylle bassler und petra neubauer am
bahnhof in kiefersfelden steht der
deutsch-österreichische grenzverkehr
bereits still und auch am dortigen
autobahngrenzübergang ist an diesem
samstag relativ wenig los
noch sind die neuen regeln nicht in
kraft noch wird hier nur kontrolliert ob
man die online registrierung für die
einreise dabei hat selbst für die
bundespolizei aber sind nicht alle
fragen beantwortet der grundsatz dass
alle personen die aus dem virus
varianten gebiet tirol kommen test
pflichtig sind die müssen einen
negativen chorfest vorweisen
inwieweit dann ausnahmen zum tragen
kommen
das muss derzeit noch geklärt werden
ausnahmen gerade für pendler hatte die
eu gefördert und die scharfen maßnahmen
kritisiert
der bundesinnenminister nun sauer jetzt
reicht's die eu kommission sollte uns
unterstützen und nicht durch wohlfeile
hinweise knüppel zwischen die beine
werfen
doch der bürgermeister von kiefersfelden
sieht durch die neuen regeln große
probleme ist doch die grenzregion hier
so eng miteinander verwoben
neben nur immer nur vorstelle in die
gemeinde beschäftigen wir natürlich
leute in die kindertagesstätten auch an
der kläranlage oder im rathaus die wir
früher also ist es immer schon
dieser kann zeigt unser starker eingriff
in unser tägliches leben bei bärenstein
im erzgebirge geht die
deutsch-tschechische grenze beinahe
mitten durch den ort noch läuft hier
alles ruhig ab viele aber machen sich
auch hier gedanken über das was nun
kommt ist aber wir denken dass eben
wieder vieles liegen bleibt die
beziehung zwischen die zwei länder ist
gewachsen über die jahre und warte jetzt
alles im prinzip zunichte gemacht
viel verunsicherung bei pendlern eine
aufgeheizte stimmung in der politik die
neuen einreisebeschränkungen und
kontrollen werfen ihre schatten voraus
die gefahr jenseits der grenze
deutschland macht dicht wer es betroffen
und welche regeln gelten
antworten auf diese und weitere fragen
in unserer zdf heute die
infektionszahlen in deutschland gehen
unterdessen weiter zurück die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt in allen
bundesländern unter 100 positive
spitzenreiter sind rheinland-pfalz und
baden-württemberg mit 51 ansteckungen
pro 100000 einwohner in einer woche
thüringen schafft es ganz knapp unter
100 innerhalb eines tages hat das lka
8354 neue ansteckungen registriert das
sind gut 2000 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 551 menschen sind in verbindung
mit cupid 19 gestorben nun in die usa
nach washington im capitol läuft ja dass
im payment verfahren gegen den
ehemaligen us-präsidenten trump die
demokraten werfen trump vor seine
anhänger im januar auf das parlament
gehetzt zu haben
eigentlich sollte heute im senat schon
abgestimmt werden doch dann hieß es
mindestens eine zeugen werden befragt
tom pollock abstimmung im senat sollen
zeugen gehört werden oder
55 senatoren stimmen für eine
zeugenbefragung darunter fünf
republikaner der anwalt trumps der
eigentlich damit gerechnet hatte dass
impeachment schnell zu beenden ist außer
sich beschimpft die anklage
sie haben die verfassung komplett
verletzt und ignoriert und draufgetreten
sie haben darauf herumgetrampelt wie
leute die keinen respekt davor haben
gestern hatten trotz anwälte ihren
mandanten vehement verteidigt mit seinen
tweets und in videos wie diesem
trump als präsident für recht und
ordnung für gerechtigkeit einer der
friedliche proteste unterstützt
die anwälte sind davon überzeugt den
wahren grund für die anklage zu kennen
es ist ganz klar geworden die
demokratischen repräsentanten hassen
diese form des politischen hasses hat
keinen platz in unserem politischen
institutionen trump aber mit seinem
kämpft die der teufel keinesfalls zu
breit aufgerufen
in einem zehnminütigen video zeigen die
anwälte wie die demokraten das wort veit
selbst benutzen
es ist okay ihr habt nichts falsch
gemacht das ist ein wort das leute
benutzen aber bitte stoppt die heuchelei
streitpunkt bleibt ob transporte
geschützt sind durch das recht auf freie
rede zeuginnen und zeugen könnten das
verfahren erheblich verlängern
james verteidigung hat angekündigt dass
sie mehr als 100 aussagen benötige dazu
immer tee sind nach washington immer im
senat überschlagen sich gerade die
ereignisse
es werden wohl doch keine zeugen gehört
heißt es jetzt was bedeutet das nun ja
also beide seiten haben sich gerade
verständigt dass sie doch keine zeugen
hören wollen weil sie befürchten dass
sich das verfahren und über tage
vielleicht über wochen noch hinaus
erstrecken könnte
es ist ein deal der gemacht wurde dafür
wurde aber jetzt die zeugenaussage
dieser republikanischen abgeordneten in
das protokoll mit aufgenommen in die
beweisaufnahme und das ist sehr wichtig
aus zwei gründen
der eine grund ist es geht hier um die
zukunft der republikanischen partei
diese abgeordnete hätte ausgesagt und
jetzt auch schriftlich wird das ins
protokoll aufgenommen dass donald trump
während des sturms auf capitol
republikanischen abgeordneten gegenüber
die hilfe verweigert hatte und sich auf
die seite der aufrührer gestellt hatte
in telefonanrufen
es geht darum dass dann künftig im
grunde genommen jeder kandidat in
zukunft für die republikanische partei
gefragt werden wird ob er damit in
ordnung ist ob das eine rechtfertigung
für gewalt und für die hetze und für die
lügen tatsächlich ist darum geht es
offenbar dieser einen republikanischen
abgeordneten sie gehört zum flügel der
nicht trump anhänger also die zukunft
optimismus der weg der partei ist oder
eben der nicht trump ismus und das
zweite was ihr wichtig ist es ist auch
ein signal ans land an die wähler
im grunde genommen ob man künftig donald
trump wieder unterstützen würde wenn er
noch einmal als präsidentschaftskandidat
2024 antreten würde
also selbst wenn jetzt und das kann
heute im laufe des tages passieren keine
mehrheit für einen schuldspruch
zusammenkommt weil es eben an einer zwei
drittel mehrheit fehlt also tram
freigesprochen wird könnte es sein dass
die wirkung die die demokraten sich von
diesem verfahren erhofft haben trotzdem
im land und in der partei der
republikanischen entfaltet wird wo
spannende hintergründe vielen dank dafür
immer nach washington
in italien haben sie heute nägel mit
köpfen gemacht das land hat einen neuen
ministerpräsidenten mario draghi früher
chef der europäischen zentralbank
die italiener setzen große hoffnungen in
ihn einer der den euro retten konnte
sagen viele
der kann auch das corona gebeutelte
italien wieder auf kurs bringen
annette hilsenbeck berichtet es soll
wohl schnell gehen die
vereidigungszeremonie bei
staatspräsident matte rabatt für mittag
angesetzt doch tatsächlich spricht der
neue ministerpräsident mario draghi den
amtseid bereits drei minuten früher als
geplant
der ehemalige ezb chef hat nach
tagelangem verhandeln den rückhalt fast
aller parteien im parlament sie sind nun
mit ministern in der regierung vertreten
dazu hat draghi experten in
schlüsselpositionen berufen
so wird dann jede franco der bisherige
direktor der italienischen zentralbank
finanzminister eine stabile regierung so
das signal die italiener erleichtert ich
habe großes vertrauen in draghi er ist
eine außergewöhnliche person
ich habe gehofft dass eine lösung findet
hoffen wir dass es funktioniert übergabe
der amtskette durch den bisherigen
premier saad bekannte frage muss nun das
angehen woran sein vorgänger gescheitert
war
einen zukunftsfähigen maßnahmenplan
erarbeitet um 209 milliarden an
finanzhilfen aus dem eu wiederaufbau
form zu erhalten mit einer mischung aus
politikern und experten will trage eine
regierung der stabilität vermitteln vor
allem nach brüssel soll das signal
ausgehen dass die gelder des eu
wiederaufbau fonds gut verwaltet werden
dafür steht vor allem der
ministerpräsident steht trage selbst mit
seinen namen die zeit drängt draghi weiß
die eu gelder müssen bis ende april
beantragt werden um italien steckt in
einer tiefen wirtschaftlichen krise
ende märz läuft das mandat für den
einsatz der bundeswehr in afghanistan
aus frieden gibt es dort aber noch nicht
trotz intensiver verhandlungen mit den
islamistischen taliban außenminister maß
schlägt deshalb vor dass man da zu
verlängern und setzt dabei auch auf die
neue us-regierung man sei sich einig
dass man den einsatz gemeinsam zu ende
führen wolle so dass der friedensprozess
nicht gefährdet werde sagte maas in
einem zeitungsinterview
die kälte hat deutschland immer noch im
griff vor allem für obdachlose ein
großes problem
es gab schon etliche tote schätzungen
zufolge leben mehr als 50.000 frauen und
männer auf der straße
viele finden zurzeit keinen platz in
einer notunterkunft andere lehnen sie ab
ihnen ist das zusammenleben mit anderen
auf engem raum fremd geworden unser
reporter dominic müller sl hat in
düsseldorf menschen begleitet die
obdachlosen in diesen kalten
helfen die königsallee eine der
top-adressen in düsseldorf es sei denn
man lebt am rand einer parkhaus einfahrt
wie robert und sein begleiter aus ungarn
dann ist es hier zur zeit
lebensgefährlich ehrenamtliche helfer
fahren seit ein paar nächten durch die
stadt um die obdachlosen zu schützen
wenn das thermometer auf bis zu elf grad
unter null fällt besorgten anwohnern
irgendwo liegt und dann fahren wir diese
stellen an und bieten unsere hilfe an
essen trinken oder schlafsack pascal
deckt sich beim hauptbahnhof mit namen
sachen für die nacht ein hirsch jeden
abend ein weiterer gute nachtbus leben
und vor allem schlafen auf der straße
ist zurzeit heftig sagt er
die stadt düsseldorf hat extra hotels
angemietet um obdachlose unterzubringen
und sie betreibt notunterkünfte mit
kleinen zimmern um die hemmschwelle von
draußen wieder reinzukommen so niedrig
wie möglich zu halten
der appell ist einfach wir machen gute
angebote bitte nehmen sie das anders ist
wirklich für sie überlebensnotwendig und
von hier aus können wir dann auch immer
weiter vermitteln
doch manche wollen einfach draußen
bleiben die hat das team vom gute
nachtbus nun besonders im blick auch
wenn sie nicht wollen so glaube ich ganz
zufrieden dass er merken dass es leute
gibt die noch mal nach den schauen
hier droht keine gefahr also weiter zur
nächsten schlafstelle unter freiem
himmel
ungefähr 100 obdachlose kümmern sich die
ehrenamtlichen helfer in düsseldorf
momentan nacht für nacht in rio de
janeiro sollte jetzt eigentlich das
leben tanzen stattdessen tobt das virus
im land die berühmteste carnevals parade
der welt mit ihren bunten masken und
wilden tänzen ein ganzes stück
brasilianische kultur ist stillgelegt
hier im legendären sambódromo übernimmt
nun das medizinische personal das feld
impfen stadt tanzen wie christoph
reckert berichtet grauer beton statt
explodierender farben statt pulsierender
samba wagen zieht eine stille prozession
durch sambodrom von rio de janeiro
der karneval hat platz gemacht für die
korona impfen
ich bin so froh ich glaube ich werde
noch über 100 jahre alt brasilien hat
spät aber entschlossen mit dem impfen
angefangen ein großteil der impfstoffe
corona wack und astrazeneca wollen sie
in lizenz selbst herstellen und in den
nächsten monaten im ganzen land
verteilen
die meisten brasilianer sind sich einig
dass die eindämmung von corona wichtiger
ist als der karneval doch die absage der
feiern hat weitreichende folgen
es geht nicht nur um kultur und
identität sondern auch um hunderte
millionen entgangene einnahmen gerade
auch für die ärmsten
der samba ist sonst in diesen tagen in
ganz rio zu hören doch heute üben nur
zwei einsame trommler in ihrer samba
schule von den vorbereitungen der wagen
kostüme choreografin leben normalerweise
tausende familien
es ist sehr sehr traurig aber es ist
besser dass wir jetzt das leben feiern
und gesund bleiben dann können wir uns
auf den karneval im nächsten jahr vor
eigentlich hat straßenhändler iran dir
einen der besten plätze direkt neben dem
sambodrom die einnahmen über karneval
machen einen großteil seines jahres
verdienstes aus jetzt ist er verzweifelt
ich fühle mich wie ein nichtsnutz ich
konnte sonst eigentlich immer etwas tun
um meine kinder und enkel zu
unterstützen
die absage des carnevals trifft
brasilien ins mark und zeigt wie ernst
die lage ist im angesicht eines virus
das sich weiter auf dem vormarsch
befindet
zum sport drittes rennen zweite medaille
für das deutsche team bei den alpinen
ski-weltmeisterschaften aber ja also
muss sagen so ein auftakt hat wirklich
lange nicht mehr gegeben und als es 1996
zum letzten mal abfahrt silber für eine
deutsche frau gab für katja seizinger
da war kira weidle gerade noch nicht
geboren punktgenau liefert die fast 25
jahre alte starnbergerin heute das beste
rennen ihrer karriere sie wird zweiter
auf der olimpia delle tofane in cortina
d'ampezzo
stolz präsentiert krawalle ihre
silbermedaille ehrt sich dann corona
konform selber für eine herausragende
leistung
dabei ist zu beginn ihrer linie noch
nicht eng genug am tor rückstand bei den
zwischenzeiten
aber dann fährt sie nahezu perfekt nach
bisher durchwachsener saison zwei fünfte
plätze stehen zu buche
ruft die 24 jährige heute eine absolute
topleistung ab beim super g am
donnerstag nur auf fragen 19 ist die
starnbergerin hier im ziel nur zwei
zehntel sekunden hinter der siegerin
corinne suter aus der schweiz auf rang
drei die super g weltmeisterin lara gut
behrami er ist dort solisten erfolgreich
und jetzt auch als mixed team tina
herrmann und christopher roth erholen
sich gemeinsam ihr zweites gold bei der
skeleton-wm
in altenberg tina herrmann hat zu recht
gute laune mit top geschwindigkeit von
111,2 km h legt die einzel-weltmeisterin
den grundstein für das dritte gold der
deutschen skeletonis einzel-weltmeister
christopher roth er glück auch im mixed
eine goldfahrt hermann grote also platz
eins vor deutschland 2 mit jacqueline
jörling und alexander gassner bronze für
das team russland wm jubel aber in
schwarz-rot-gold eine medaille verpasst
hat denise herrmann bei den biathlon
weltmeisterschaften auf der pokljuka in
slowenien ein fehlschuss im stehen
beschert der oberwiesenthalerin im
sprint über 7,5 kilometer eine
strafrunde schließlich fehlen hier acht
sekunden zur bronzemedaille
gold holt sich die fehlerfrei schießende
norwegerinnen kerkhoff die 22 sekunden
weniger benötigt als vier spiele kein
sieger das ist die nachmittags bilanz in
der fußball bundesliga dortmund
enttäuscht erneut 2 2 gegen hoffenheim
leverkusen verspielt in den
schlussminuten die 2 0 führung gegen
mainz bremen freiburg 0 zu 0 und
stuttgart hertha bsc eins zu eins am
abend union gegen schalke gestern
leipzig augsburg 21 klub-weltmeister
bayern spielt erst am montag gegen
bielefeld leipzig bleibt auf jeden fall
zweiter dahinter kann es nach abschluss
des 21
spieltages etwas anders aussehen als
heute unten rückt mainz bis auf drei
punkte an den relegationsplatz heran
allerdings ist bielefeld momentan mit
zwei spielen im rückstand
und wie schalke bei union gespielt hat
sehen sie ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr wie immer dank
genauer wird morgen gibt's nochmal viel
sonnenschein mehr zum wetter und wie es
weitergeht hat gleich ist intern so viel
von uns danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie heute um
drei viertel elf zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da um
19 uhr einen gemütlichen samstagabend
wünschen wir uns
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die eisige kälte
hält sich noch bei uns wird aber von
westen her allmählich angeknabbert und
sie sehen hier diesen blauen bereich das
ist die kaltluft die allmählich nach
osten abgeschoben wird und in den
nächsten tagen wird es nach und nach
allmählich bilder in der nacht gibt es
kaum worten nur nach osten hin und die
können durchaus auch mal dichter seien
vor allem richtung erzgebirge und das
bei tiefsten temperaturen von minus 20
grad in der mitte also sehr strenger
frost ansonsten kann es häufig unter die
minus zehn grad marke sinken
im westen ist der frost etwas schwächer
mit minus 6 grad und auch an der ostsee
morgen im tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein
fast überall im osten gibt es einige
wenige wolken und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von minus sechs grad im
osten deutschlands das ist der
höchstwert hier und plus 6 grad im
westen also hier ist es schon mal
frostfrei die nächsten tage am montag
kommt im westen regen und schnee auf es
wird gefährlich class überquert uns
einmal nach osten und erreicht am abend
die oder bei temperaturen von minus zwei
bis plus acht grad und ab dienstag wird
es von westen her immer milder damit ein
schöner abend